this episode is sponsored by ren a
website where you can calculate your
carbon emissions you can also sign up to
make a monthly contribution to offset
your emissions or support rainforest
production projects by clicking our link
in the description
when it comes to the muses of the animal
kingdom the nematode seems like an
unlikely well of inspiration there may
be poems about tigers burning bright and
epic fantasy tales featuring giant birds
but nematodes have two obvious factors
working against them achieving that kind
of mythical status
first they are worms and let's not
generalize too broadly but their simple
tubular bodies are just not what most
people think of when it comes to the
beauty of the natural world
second most of them are really tiny
their length measured in millimeters
it's hard to be inspired by an animal
that is likely to escape one's notice
entirely
though we should note here that there
are nematodes that can grow quite long
the largest ever discovered was found in
the placenta of a sperm whale and it
measured between eight and nine meters
in length but even that seems more
likely to inspire more nightmares than
art
in 1914 a scientist named nathan cobb
wrote the following about nematodes
nematodes do not furnish hides horns
tallow or wool they are not fit for food
they do not produce anything fit to eat
neither do they sing or amuse us in any
way nor are they ornamental in fact when
they are displayed in museums the public
votes them hideous
judging from that quote cobb seems to
understand the common consensus on
nematodes which is that if there is to
be a consensus it is not a positive one
but cobb wrote this as part of a 34-page
paper on nematodes titled nematodes and
their relationships which wonderfully
documents his fascination with the worm
and argues for their importance to our
understanding of the world so clearly he
found something inspiring about the
nematode but there is another quote from
this research paper that you may have
even heard before it is pretty famous in
nematode circles and the quote is as
follows
in short if all the matter in the
universe except the nematodes were swept
away our world would still be dimly
recognizable and if as disembodied
spirits we could then investigate it we
should find its mountains hills veils
rivers lakes and oceans represented by a
film
of nematodes
cobb paints a world overrun by nematodes
an image created by his own experience
with studying them but when he wrote
this he likely didn't have the means to
estimate just how many nematodes there
are in the world
but by 2019 researchers had estimated
that there are around 57 billion
nematodes in the world
for every human in the world
in addition their total biomass is about
300 million tons and that's just for the
soil nematodes when you take into
consideration nematodes living in
freshwater or marine habitats or inside
other animals the numbers can only go up
from there
nematodes are considered to be one of
the most abundant animals on earth
but the beauty of cobb's riding on their
abundance is that he doesn't just
capture the notion of the numbers the
world he describes isn't just a mass of
worms that we've been allowed space
inside of the world he describes the one
that we live in has its forms and
landscapes sculpted and cultivated by
worms their bodies shaped around and
inside trees and plants and animals
of course not all of those links between
nematodes and other organisms are always
so pleasant in nematodes in their
relationships cobb mentions that he once
removed over 40 000 nematodes from the
stomach of a wallaby and if that isn't
daunting enough to imagine there are
always the ancient texts that date back
thousands of years documenting
intestinal worms found in people
there are also the nematode eggs that
have been found preserved in mummies and
in fossilized poop
in the 19th century scientists were able
to show that the parasite ascorous
lumbricoides which resides in the
intestines and produces eggs that are
passed on through poop finds its way
into people who have ingested their eggs
on contaminated food to prove this a
scientist named giovanni batista grazie
infected himself with their eggs and
then hunted for those eggs in his feces
a peculiar side here this is not the
first time we have described a scientist
hunting through his own poop for
evidence of the microcosmos you can
watch our lavender episode for more
tales of this type
now there are plenty of other nematode
parasites that have their own unique
life cycles and horrifying effects some
worms are transmitted through the soil
others through insects some inflame the
limbs others trigger massive blood loss
nematodes can also parasitize plants
attacking their roots or stem or flowers
sometimes destroying entire crops in the
process
and so with such a destructive path the
nematode feels like an enemy something
we study only to understand how we can
fight it
but cobb asks a simple question in his
writing
what would be our conception of the
insect group as a whole if our knowledge
was largely confined to these simple and
degenerate parasitic forms
in the case of insects we have enough
experience with them to know that
whatever squeamishness they inspire they
are also integral parts of our world and
likewise most nematodes are actually
free living species it's just the
parasites have come to dominate both our
imagination and our knowledge because of
their proximity and their consequences
to our health but those massively
abundant soil nematodes
they are vital to our world feeding on
bacteria and fungi in the process they
release nitrogen back into the soil
sustaining other organisms and plants
that may use it
a healthy soil is full of these free
living nematodes whose presence reflects
the overall diversity of microbes around
them the information is all there it is
up to us to uncover their secrets
perhaps this is why cobb ended nematodes
in their relationships with this call to
arms for the field of nematology
they offer an exceptional field of study
and probably constitute among the last
great organic group worthy of a separate
branch of biological science comparable
with entomology
nematology
we can't speak to any claims that the
nematode is the quote last great organic
group worthy of its own branch of study
but we do feel that he has been
vindicated by the fact that one of the
most popular model organisms used today
is a free-living nematode cenorabiditis
elegans better known as c elegans while
the worm is found in soils all over the
world what it's perhaps best known for
is the life it lives in labs
while scientists had described various
aspects of c elegans life early in the
20th century it wasn't until
1965 that the scientist sydney brenner
turned to the worm as a model organism
relying on its fast life cycle small
size and capability to produce more than
a thousand eggs a
day there were those who thought that
the worm's simplicity would render it
useless in studies of morphology and
behavior but time and technology has
turned c elegans into a molecular muse
it has taught us about how life develops
how human diseases progress and how
cells die
when cobb wrote quote my experience in
this matter makes me very confident in
saying that professors of biology could
do far worse than to introduce into
their courses a more careful examination
of these creatures he did not know that
one day many of those professors of
biology wouldn't just be introducing
nematodes into their courses they would
be introducing them into their labs
when cobb died in 1932 scientists didn't
even know how genetic information was
encoded in dna
more than 50 years later c elegans
became the first multicellular organism
to have its genome sequenced
and as it continues to teach us about
our world nasa has even sent them to
space so we can learn about how life
ages outside of this planet so maybe the
nematode is not the muse we expected but
over the last century they have become
one nonetheless and perhaps that is the
most fitting testament to what a muse
often actually is a surprising source of
inspiration that seems to come from
nowhere and then
permeates until you see it everywhere
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us and thank you again to
ren for sponsoring this episode of
journey to the micro cosmos
ren is a website where you can calculate
your carbon emissions and then offset
them by funding projects like community
tree planting in east africa or a
project that helps prevent wildfires in
california by removing dead and
flammable trees and turning them into
biochar
we will need a lot of different
approaches to stop the climate crisis
and this is one way you can learn more
about your carbon contribution and take
some action you'll answer a few
questions about your lifestyle and
they'll also show you ways that you can
start reducing your carbon emissions no
one can reduce their footprint to zero
but using ren you can offset what you
have left
once you sign up you'll receive updates
from the tree planting rainforest
protection and other projects you
support and we have partnered with ren
to protect an extra 10 acres of
rainforest for the first 100 people who
sign up using our link in the
description
[Music]
remember now that there are 57 billion
nematodes for every person and that also
goes for every person whose name is on
the screen right now each of those
people have 57
billion nematodes on earth just for them
and i want to say thank you to those
particular nematodes for being the
corresponding nematodes to our patreon
patrons who are the people who make it
possible for us to make this show those
nematodes don't know how good this show
is but they should know that this is now
probably one of the finest pieces of
nematode propaganda on earth so they
should be very thankful to all of our
patrons as we here at journey to the
micro cosmos are if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes james
weiss you can check out jam and germs on
instagram and if you want to see more
from us
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
you